Most people assume that experiments in science
are usually very expensive and are very resource
intensive.
However, this is not always true.
Not all experiments require many resources.
Let’s talk about the work of Alfred Hershey
and Martha Chase for example.
Did you know that the Hershey and Chase experiment
was one of the most remarkable works in the
field of genetics?
What was the experiment about?
And what does it help us infer?
Let us find that out!
In the timeline of the history of Genetics
that we looked at, we have reached this point.
So let us step ahead and jump to the year 1952.
Two American geneticists, Alfred Hershey and
Martha Chase, carried out a very simple experiment
that helped figure out whether “DNA” was
really the “Transformation Principle”
or not.
The experiment was quite simple!
It just required a culture medium, two different
radioactive isotopes, a mixer blender and
a centrifuge tube.
A culture medium is a medium used to grow
different kinds of microorganisms.
With this equipment they carried out an experiment
using a bacteriophage and a bacterial strain.
Let us find out how the experiment was framed.
Before that, can you tell me what bacteriophage is?
The term “PHAGE” means virus.
So the name “bacteriophage” stands for
virus that infects “bacteria”.
So bacteriophages usually infect the host
bacterium by inserting their genetic material
into them.
And they make copies of themselves using the
replication machinery of the host bacterium.
The interesting thing here is that the body
of any bacteriophage is simply made up of
two components: the outer protein coat and
the inner genetic material.
Now let us get back to the Hershey and Chase
experiment.
The main aim of their experiment was to find
out what exactly is the genetic material.
Is it proteins or DNA?
Since the phage contains only proteins and
DNA, it is easier to find out which component
gets into the host bacterium.
They simply used radiolabelled markers to
identify the different strains.
So if the bacterial cells have the radioactively
marked proteins in the end, then it is the
proteins which are the genetic material.
On the other hand, if the radiolabelled DNA
makes its way into the bacterial cell, then
probably the DNA is the genetic material!
So the experiment was quite simple!
They first obtained radiolabelled bacteriophages.
One strain had the radiolabelled proteins
and the other had radiolabelled DNA.
Then they allowed these different bacteriophages
to separately infect the bacteria.
And at the end, they analysed the bacteria
to find out which radiolabelled component
had made its way into it!
But how did they obtain the radiolabelled
proteins and DNA?
What was the process they used?
And how were the results analysed at the end?
Let us find that out in the next part!
Hershey and Chase used bacteriophages which
are the viruses that infect the bacteria.
We know that their bodies are made up of only
proteins and DNA.
That makes it easier to figure out what gets
into the host bacterial cells.
The experiment was quite simple!
They first obtained radiolabelled bacteriophages.
There were two different types: ones having
radiolabelled proteins and the others with
radiolabelled DNA.
Then they allowed these different bacteriophages
to separately infect the bacteria.
And at the end, they analysed the bacteria
as to which radiolabelled component had made
its way into it!
This is how the simple experiment helped answer
a few important queries.
Now let us get into the details of
this experiment
and understand it step by step!
The first thing Hershey and Chase did was
that they obtained the radiolabelled phage
strains.
In one nutrient medium they added the radio
isotope Sulphur 35 which is S-35.
In the other, they added Phosphorous 32 which
is P-32.
But why only sulphur and phosphorous?
And that too in separate mediums?
Well, sulphur is an integral part of proteins,
but is not present in the DNA.
On the other hand, phosphorous is present
in the DNA but not in proteins.
Thus, for easy analysis, they chose the radio-isotopes
of these two elements.
So one nutrient medium was added with the
sulphur 35 radioisotope.
The bacteria grown in this medium thus had
S-35 incorporated into their bodies.
Now what will happen if bacteriophages are
allowed to infect these bacteria?
It is obvious that S-35 will get incorporated
in the protein coats of these bacteriophages
as well!
That is because, these are derived from the
body of these host bacteria.
So their first batch of S-35 labelled bacteriophages
was ready!
Similarly, in this culture medium, they added
P32 and allowed the growth of bacterial colonies.
As a result, all the bacteriophages obtained
post infection, had radiolabelled DNA.
So the second batch of bacteriophages with
radiolabelled DNA was also ready with them!
Now all they had to do is allow these radioactively
marked bacteriophages to infect new bacterial
cells.
These host cells will be the ones harbouring
the new phage generations, which will help
analyse what has passed down the line.
So they infected the bacterial cells with
the two batches separately.
After several hours of infection, the cultures
were agitated in a mixer blender.
Why is this step necessary?
It is needed to make sure that post infection,
the empty phage coats get separated from the
bacterial cells.
The agitation helps release the empty phage
coats attached to the bacterial cells.
Now in the next step they centrifuged the
culture at an extremely high speed.
Centrifugation process works on the principle
of gravitational force.
So when the sample is centrifuged at a very
high speed, the heavier, denser particles
settle at the bottom, while the lighter particles
remain on top.
What is settled at the bottom is usually called
pellet, while the one that floats on top is
called supernatant.
So the centrifugation step helped Hershey
and Chase to obtain two layers.
The one on top was supernatant and the one
at the bottom was pellet.
They checked the radioactivity in both the
batches and concluded their analysis.
Before we reach the conclusions, can you help
Nora guess the interpretation?
What will be the interpretation if the radioactivity
is found in the supernatant?
And what will be the inference if it is found
in the pellet?
Think about it!
Let me help you with this!
The supernatant contains phage ghosts which
are the empty shells or coats of phage.
It does not have the replicated next generations
of the bacteriophages.
Similarly, the pellet will contain the bacterial
cells, and the newer phage particles.
So now, in case one, if the radioactivity
is observed in the supernatant, then it means
that the marker is only present in the protein
coat of the phage, and did not get into the
bacterial cells.
This can help us conclude that the proteins
are not the genetic material as the newly
formed phage particles did not receive S-35.
On the other hand, if the radioactivity is
seen in the pellet, then it would mean that
the newer phage cells have all got the radioactive
P-32 in them.
Thus, the DNA, in the form of genetic material
has successfully got transferred in the new
phage particles.
This is what the analysis of both the cases can be!
Let us look at the results Hershey and Chase obtained.
On analysing the first sample, they found
that the radioactivity was present in the
supernatant.
And in the second batch, the radioactivity
was found in the pellet.
What did this mean?
That’s right!
With this, the two concluded that it is the
DNA which is the genetic material and not
proteins.
If proteins would have been the genetic material,
then the pellet in the first batch would have
shown the presence of radioactive S35.
Instead, the pellet in the second batch showed
the presence of P32.
Thus, it was confirmed that it is the DNA
which is the genetic material!
With this, Avery, MacLeod and McCarty’s
analysis that Griffith’s “TRANSFORMING
PRINCIPLE” was DNA, was also proved!
Thus, the long ignored DNA molecule now rose
to fame, and scientists all over the globe
started working on finding its structure.
But how was the structure discovered?
And what does the actual structure of a DNA
molecule look like?
Let us find that out in the next part!